-Performing his new single,
"Water Under the Bridge,"
give it up for Sam Hunt!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I can't believe
this ol' road ain't washed out ♪
♪ That "No trespassing" sign
is still hangin' around ♪
♪ And it's doin' about
as much good now
as it did back then ♪
♪ Yeah, you know
we used to load up on
Natty, unleaded, and smokes ♪
♪ Hide from the sheriff and
let down our folks ♪
♪ Parked some old Chevy jukebox
up here on the bank ♪
♪ Crank it till the thing
won't crank ♪
♪ That muddy river,
it was rollin' ♪
♪ We didn't care
where it was goin' ♪
♪ We had it made,
we didn't know it ♪
♪ We were young, dumb,
and so full of it ♪
♪ Broken bottles and graffiti ♪
♪ Beer and girls
and poppin' wheelies ♪
♪ Love was fun,
and life was easy ♪
♪ Now it's just
water under the bridge ♪
♪ Well, I kissed a girl
my buddy used to like ♪
♪ He showed up out
here and he wanted to fight ♪
♪ Now I still talk to him,
but I don't know where she is ♪
♪ Guess it's just
water under the bridge ♪
♪ That muddy river,
it was rollin' ♪
♪ We didn't care
where it was goin' ♪
♪ We had it made,
we didn't know it ♪
♪ We were young, dumb,
and so full of it ♪
♪ Broken bottles and graffiti ♪
♪ Beer and girls
and poppin' wheelies ♪
♪ Love was fun,
and life was easy ♪
♪ Now it's just
water under the bridge ♪
♪ Oh, it's all just
water up under the bridge ♪
♪♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ That muddy river,
it was rollin' ♪
♪ We didn't care
where it was goin' ♪
♪ We had it made,
we didn't know it ♪
♪ We were young, dumb,
and so full of it ♪
♪ Broken bottles and graffiti ♪
♪ Beer and girls
and poppin' wheelies ♪
♪ Love was fun,
and life was easy ♪
♪ Now it's just
water under the bridge ♪
♪ Oh, it's all just
water up under the bridge ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, it's all just
water under the bridge ♪
♪♪
♪ It's all just water ♪
♪ It's all just water
under the bridge ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, come on, now!